NARRATOR: An estimated
40% of Americans
are descended from
immigrants that
passed through Ellis Island.
That's a lot of Americans.
The first Ellis Island
immigration station
opened on January 1,
1892 in New York Harbor
to manage the increasing number
of migrants coming to America.
In that first year, a record
number of nearly 450,000 people
passed through to enter
the United States.
By the time Ellis
Island closed in 1954,
that number had
reached 12 million,
although most of those
people arrived by 1924.
Migrants fleeing
poverty and persecution
or just looking to
start a new life
traveled by private
steamship from Eastern
and Southern Europe.
Voyages could take
one to two weeks.
Ships divided passengers
by wealth and class.
First- and
second-class passengers
slept in state rooms and
cabins while everyone
else stayed in a
space at the bottom
of the ship called steerage.
Steerage passengers paid
around $30 per ticket,
but steamship companies
would sell as many tickets
as they could.
First- and second-class
passengers paid even more.
Because of this,
steerage was often
overcrowded and unsanitary
with shared sleeping
compartments and no privacy.
But hopeful immigrants
stuck it out,
believing it would be
worth it for a chance
to live in the United States.
When ships finally arrived
in New York Harbor,
health officers boarded and
looked for signs of disease
before anyone was
allowed to disembark.
Healthy first- and
second-class passengers
were processed on
the spot and allowed
to enter the United
States without setting
foot on Ellis Island.
Everyone else waited,
sometimes for days,
for small ferries to take
them to the immigration
station for processing.
Migrants walked
down the gangplank
with all of their
belongings and dropped
their bags in the baggage
room on the ground floor.
They then continued
up a winding staircase
to the Registry Room, which
was upstairs for a reason.
Doctors stood on
the second floor
and watched each
person climb the stairs
for signs of health problems.
The Registry Room,
nearly 20,000 square feet
with 56-foot-tall
vaulted ceilings,
was nicknamed the Great
Hall for its size.
It was here that most migrants'
fate would be decided.
The first step to entry was
a six-second physical exam
by a uniformed doctor.
Anyone considered a
risk to public health
was marked with a piece of
chalk and taken out of the line
to be examined further.
Marks were given for everything
from signs of mental illness
to trachoma, a
contagious eye infection
that could eventually blind
up to 3/4 of those infected.
Those who cleared
the medical exam
went on to a legal inspection.
Passengers were checked against
a manifest from the ship they
arrived on and
asked 29 identifying
questions, often with the
help of an interpreter.
If their answers didn't
match the information
on the manifest, things
like their name, occupation,
and country of origin,
they could be detained.
The legal interviews could
take as little as two minutes,
and the vast majority of
people passed through with ease
and were allowed to enter the
country after being issued
landing cards with their
name, often misspelled,
and destination.
For others, the stay on Ellis
Island was considerably longer.
The few who were detained for
either medical or legal reasons
could be on the island
overnight or for months.
Once their records
were finally reviewed,
they would either be
admitted to the US
or sent back to the country
they came from free of charge.
But only 2% of the
12 million immigrants
processed at Ellis Island
were deported in this way.
After inspection,
everyone continued down
a staircase with three aisles.
Those being detained walked
down the center aisle.
Those entering New York
City or headed north
walked down the left, and
those traveling west or south
walked down the right.
At the bottom was a post
office, a rail ticket office,
and a place to change money--
for some, family
waiting to greet them,
and for all a new
life in America.